I've always been a fan of systemic games
I mean I grew up really I'm playing
civilization since the first one that
came out and I'll play every version of
every civilization every add-on pack
forever
XCOM is oh another one my favorite games
I grew up playing paper you know hex
based board games but my games that I've
worked on haven't really been like that
with the exception of freedom for so a
little bit but narrative and systemic
they kind of fight with each other and
so we haven't really been able to sort
of make you know really integrate system
work as much as possible so to do
something really different we really had
to go back to the drawing board and that
required a new structure a smaller group
of people and time that was the most
important thing time to fail time to
fail for a long period where you don't
have a hundred and fifty people who are
looking you saying dude you know what am
I supposed to be doing today I want to
say a couple things that this is not
this talk is not a design for a specific
game I'm not here to pitch a product
it's a GDC talk this you're all
developers I'm a developer this is just
early or early thoughts on something
that I want to put out there this is not
like a specific development plan where
oh my god they cut that feature there's
no features here yet we're just really
talking on a very high level it's not an
intellectual property or you see nothing
here like a rapture or Columbia you're
going to see me stealing a lot of meta
intellectual property from other people
that were just using for the purpose of
example and for headline if you're
journalists and your headline says
Lavigne reveals new game you've written
the wrong [ __ ] headline but one of
you will write it I guarantee it all the
content here you're going to see is
basically just stolen from other places
and from other great games but it's the
content the the kind of worlds the kind
of characters it's just for it's just
for the purposes of example so but what
that's a lot of what this isn't what
this is it's a conversation it's my way
of contributing to a conversation which
i think is already going on a lot of
people I respect in the industry have
been thinking about some of these
things and this is me and my team trying
to bring our sort of approach to it Boop
and that's my powerpoint skills at work
so it's our initial scratching in there
to try to figure out a way to really
make player driven is the key words
player driven replayable narrative they
do okay so I want to say one thing a lot
of times these talks are like well don't
record this don't do it don't take
pictures don't do anything like that
this is completely open source take
pictures film it put it on the internet
whatever you want to do you know do a
riff tracks to it I don't care and but
you know tweet it and most importantly
if it's something useful to you steal
whatever you want from it I don't know
how much it's going to be useful cuz
it's pretty early but there's nothing
proprietary here that you should be
remotely nervous about leveraging for
your own stuff alright so we talked some
of the negatives of linear narrative the
it's incredibly expensive to make the
individual pieces don't speak to each
other they do emotionally like what
happened to Booker at the beginning of
infinite talk to what happened at the
end and the player's mind but the game
there's nothing in the game in a way in
Civilization your choices you make at
the beginning really make make an effect
at the end like in a meaningful
meaningful way you know which which you
know types of cities you build which
types of of cultural trees you've taken
they don't really do that in linear
narrative branching does exist a lot of
games not so much in our games but
there's still X number of states and
what I want to talk today is not X
number of states but X to the Y number
of states
I haven't taken math since 1983 so I
think that's right
it also linear narrative doesn't really
fully embrace the Pat unique power of
games which is replayable and player
driven you know as much as I love the
narratives we did really we we were so
much feeling you know we knew the
constraints with so much that we kind of
made a lot of meta commentary on
constraints because we it is a
constraint and although I love that form
I think we sort of said what we had to
say
and we want to see what's past it most
importantly it's not player-driven
you are seeing the same story your
friend is seeing or you're seeing X of Y
versions of a story your friend is
seeing multiple endings still mean a
fixed number of player states there's
five endings there's not X to the Y and
things and one of the most frustrating
parts for me is you can only add it in
to a narrative game traditionally sorry
add on to a narrative game meaning
here's another chunk which you play that
it's subsequent to what you already
played Wii games like civilization games
like XCOM you can add in to the
experience and enhance the experience in
the very beginning of the game so that's
going to be a focus in what we talk
about today as well
I don't want to underplay the work
that's being done in this area I think
you know if you look at supper Bioware
the stuff at Pinot The Witcher guys are
doing there's a lot of really great work
about opening up a narrative but I think
they're taking a fundamentally different
approach but I don't and no way what do
I want to say their work is an
extraordinary and important so how do we
traditionally think about AI whenever I
talk to people about AI a lot of people
say to me when do you think an AI is
going to be like a person when is it
going to pass the Turing test and I
think that's fundamentally too ambitious
a way to think about characters in a
eyes because I think we've all
demonstrate there's nobody on the planet
who's even close to this I think we're
several paradigm shifts of not just
technology as a writer it's hard enough
to write one good character let alone a
character that can react to any
arbitrary thing and say clever and funny
lines while he does it so a really
robust solution to this lies beyond any
technology or creative horizon that we
currently have so we're really
scratching at the surface but I think
we're giving up the good for the great
because I think there's real major steps
we can make here but we have to refocus
our attention a little bit if you're
over too ambitious can lead to paralysis
and I think that's what happens well we
can't do it so let's just not even
really try so let's try some first steps
physics remember when physics member 20
years ago there was no physics and games
physics was an animation that played
when you drop something that had no did
not speak to any math really of any kind
but when they started with physics and I
got very excited cuz I love simulation
they started very simply with you know
2d circles and rectangles and spheres
and cylinders and axis aligned boxes and
you know so on and so on and so on now
there's cloth and liquid but they're
still dealing with a subset and they
keep building up from that subset but
every time they add something for that
subset it gets more powerful it gets
more real feeling but remember back in
the day when the first things appeared
it wasn't you weren't like oh [ __ ] this
it's not perfect physics let's forget it
I'm not going to play it it was exciting
and I think that there's there's a path
to take here with characters so if we
don't try to model everything but motto
will limp a set of limited and
believable and impactful things so let's
try as we think about this to set some
goals create a narrative lis driven
experience where the narrative elements
are nonlinear and they talk to each
other they interact with each other they
bounce off one another like I was about
to make some science reference and again
I was a drama major so I completely
blanked in what that reference would be
like electrons or atoms that's not right
okay
and all these narrative elements trigger
off a player action not off authorial
action me not like we decide I get an
infinite for instance and you enter a
bounding ball generally narrative think
what happened when you enter a bounding
box and we say oh you enter the bounding
box and conditions x y&z your Metsa will
trigger this narrative event but those
are generally off of where the author
intends than to happen not where the
player arranges for them to happen these
triggers these things that change the
narrative state the things you can
interact with them there have to be
transparent to the player so you're not
just like out there doing things and
people are reacting in completely crazy
ways we want to show you that the things
that the
the passions and I'll talk to you about
what passions are in a minute what they
are and how you can interact with them
so let's hope Howard Howard isn't here
but let's just serve take his did you
know their design and you know a lot of
MMO style design and single-player and
I'm a like Skyrim design basic so we
have a game we can talk about that isn't
necessarily in any way shape or form the
game we're making but it gives you some
basis of understanding to apply the new
stuff to so let's assume a game kind of
open-world II with factions you can
choose between what quests and character
growth and you know armor to collect and
monsters to fight and crafting of all
kinds
I would expand my crafting in a I take a
page out dark clouds book for this
example to dark cloud to hope you've all
played it's like when the best games
ever you can actually craft there you go
you can actually craft actual towns and
buildings and those there's a cycle you
go the dungeon you collect loot you
collect crafting materials you come back
to the town you can build parts of the
town that gives you buffs that gives you
new characters that gives you
opportunities there's a great cycle what
I talk about here is this strong loop
between non combat in combat a really
strong non combat combat loop non-linear
quest structure is also critical here
alright so here's my incredibly
innovative world four villages imagine
an open world ii kind of thing it's an
orc village it's a dwarf village there
is a goblin village and a elf village
and there's you you come into the world
and so now we start getting into the
stuff that is the stuff we've been
thinking about and the stuff where we've
been focusing our brain on so in the orc
village there's lots of people there's
five stars in each town now that number
is is placeholder but what I want is
that when I say a star these are the
characters that really matter and the
question is I don't want to overwhelm
the player with a thousand characters
that matter because you just you just
won't be able to track them so the
number is really how many people can be
can the player really track how many
stars can play a track okay what is a
star a star is an NPC
with a set of capital P passions the
define term which I'll define in a
minute
what's fashion ok these are not full
psychological models you know as I said
tech before has been trying to really
fully simulate a human being you know
you know how they work but I'm not
really trying to do that let's go to
literature and media so you know a bunch
of stuff about Luke Skywalker he has
passions right what are Luke's passions
he wants to prove himself he wants to go
on adventures he has issues with his dad
these are things that really define him
there's things that probably exist we
all have things that exist and think
about just free about Luke just for
other people you know people you work
with you know a bunch of about their
passions but like you don't really know
about their kinky weird [ __ ] that goes
on at home and maybe you don't even want
her now
so there are things that don't really
matter you know maybe Luke is a
vegetarian maybe it's one of those
really jerky vegetarians who won't stop
I'm a vegetarian so I kind of know he's
got probably he's had a terrible tooth
decay problem he's got OCD and like
these are things that exist in Luke
Skywalker but they're just not relevant
to to the experience at hand so let's
not worry about that stuff let's just
worry about his passions so passion is
what a star cares about relative to the
actions of the player meaning relative
to the things the player can impact upon
a passion is transparent to the player
meaning that the player can see these
passions and see how they are the
character the NPC is feeling about them
in relation to these passions a passion
must be responsive to player's actions
it has no meaning if you can't do
anything about it
that's what you know you're you're the
star you're the center of this game you
want to be able to impact these passions
so let's meet Frank one of the stars of
the orc village he's a blacksmith he is
a store hey guess what he sells a lot of
armor and weapons and crap like that but
unlike most blacksmiths who just stand
there and deal with you on price Frank's
a little more complicated he's he's kind
of a deep guy he's got three passions
let's just talk about one of those
passions he has a passion which is he
hates elves and a lot of Alex share this
passion
and guess who the cursor I'm drawing
with here yeah there it is oh it's great
it's completely offset from my screen so
so you see that every all the characters
have passions or feelings about you in
regard to this thing so Frank here is
about hating elves but this is really
about how does he feel about you in
relation to hating elves well he doesn't
know you at first so he's like he's
neutral with you you know he's right in
the middle but as you do things relative
to LZ thir doing bad crap to elves or
doing good stuff to elves he likes you
more or less in regard to this passion
okay so example Frank hate elves you
kill an elf who he likes you for that
and his passion in this regard would
move towards the positive nice and
simple on the other side he hates elves
you help an elf of any kind you know you
do a quest for an elf you rescuing help
you build a house for an elf you Wuan
out he's gonna feel more negative about
this that's all pretty simple and you've
seen some stuff like this in games
before already so he but he had Frank
has three passions you know about the
beginning let's have the passions or he
hates elves he wants a temple to the old
gods built not the new gods the old gods
and he wants to woo Barbara the orc
because she's beautiful and you can
impact all these passions you could help
him build the temple you can help him
prove himself to Barbara all you know
these are all normals requesting things
and building things and cracking things
and fighting things and Dungeon II
things and collecting things but they're
all impact impacted by you these won't
move on their own except that what you
do relative to them now the macro
passion okay this is where it gets
interesting to me the macro patch action
macro passion and this is where my math
won't come in again I'm going to say
it's a function I'm going to say it's an
average and I'm probably completely
wrong because it's probably somebody
tell me it can't be an average but I'm
saying it's an average of shut up
it's it's a function or an average of
the three of the three micro passions
yield basically their overall feeling
about you and remember so it's not just
one feeling it moves on all these
different axes those yields a larger
feeling about
shoo and you see these little black
lines on these on the Omni on the macro
passion that's that gold bar those are
call thresholds and when that when you
pass certain thresholds on that Frank
will start doing stuff for you or doing
stuff against you depending on how your
deal with dealing with Frank so for
instance you um steal the L king's crown
remember he does not like elves
so that micro passion feeds in the macro
passion and ding oh hi mrs. slide you
kill some elves in the beginning
ding Frank says oh guess why there's 20
percent discount in my store from now on
as long as you don't go back past that
threshold as you do things he doesn't
like then you do something bigger you
you steal an L king's crown ding Frank
offers to send NPCs henchmen to help you
in battle that will appear sometimes
just when you need them now player
destroys an elf shrine no ding because
you actually haven't crossed the
threshold but you're moving along the
bar so it's still good but you haven't
hit an actual threshold for a thing now
you thought I started hanging out with
the elves and you know that's the wrong
thing oh no sorry my mistake
um you you helped build his temple so
the old gods that he likes ding he makes
a special item for sale I think you get
the idea now on the other side you spell
out the elves and maybe you come you
kind of like one of the elves and you do
a quest for one of them well Frank's
gonna hear about that unde inge you know
his his micro passion of elves will move
back a little bit and maybe enough to
actually affect the macro passion bar
and that special item that was on the
shelf goes off the shelf because he and
he will reflect all this in his dialogue
with you yeah dude her what you did with
the elves not [ __ ] cool you know
feeding this back is all really really
important I'm going to take a little
sidestep here and talk about zero-sum
games and they can be very important to
what we're talking about here you may be
sensing this already ten dollars to
anybody spots the math error which I
forgot to fix um so a zero-sum game is
say there's ten gold and the cannon
Pierre both want the 10 gold and either
10 in
could have a bunch of situations I got
10 he's got none I've got zero he's got
10 I got 3 he's got 7 I've got 6 he's
got 5 drama major but it's a zero-sum
game meaning if he gains I lose I gain
he loses then there's nonzero of some
games
let me use lucky charms because I like
lucky charms in example say I've got a
surplus of blue moons and Pierre has a
surplus of pink hearts more than we can
possibly eat but we really both want we
want the variety it's really important
for our economy we can trade so I give
my surplus to him this isn't it was
classic this is what trade is right he
gives me his surplus and now we both
have much better economies because we
have this mixture of resources we need
that's a non zero sum game zero-sum
means you can't please everyone and
we're going to leverage zero-sum in this
design substantially so for instance
Frank and Pete hate elves player helps
Romeo the elf and the and the and Frank
and Pete like you less so the ogre the
elbows like you more that elf likes you
more maybe other I was like more but
they're going to like you less zero-sum
but there's even a zero-sum between in
villages themselves Frank the orc loves
the old gods well Pete the orc is a
cleric for the new gods and every time
you help build the old God temple we're
going to piss the orc off now you can
trade them off against each other
because remember these aren't unilateral
each character has three or more
passions so you can really piss peed off
in regard to the temple but you can help
them out in other areas and you have to
balance all these things off one another
but they're all going to be transparent
to you and we have to have a limited
number of them so you can really track
this also it just doesn't become a giant
spreadsheet that overwhelms you but you
know you as I said you're damned if you
do if you do and if you don't let's talk
about the love that dare not speak its
name
so orc and elf we have julia the orc is
in love with romeo the elf now most of
the orcs want bad crap to happen to the
elves
except for Juliet so you can go all day
and pound on the elves and all the orcs
thing I love you but you're very pissing
off Juliet so she's for instance the
priestess in the temple and she gives
the healing well she's Lee you're going
to have a hard time getting that healing
from her but if you help Romeo she's
going to herb who was going to going to
go up there's me a lot of works who
don't like that so even within villages
they're not they're not a monoculture
they all have different hopes and dreams
and feelings so we talked about
characters you know why only five
characters in each city well there's
going to be a lot more characters but
there will be what I call drones and
they're very simple they're macro bar
they just have a macro bar is a function
of all the other of the stars in that
towns macro bars and basically they're
just going to be guards and hire lines
and Scouts and spies and foragers and
and shopkeepers but who aren't
complicated but they just they just sort
of feel generally how the town feels
about you but they won't be able to give
you the kind of benefits that the stars
would be able to give you so that will
populate the world but not with millions
of stars I'm a bit too deep into this
slide but there's like a whole list of
things you can accomplish for people you
probably see them a lot of them in other
games some of them could be new you know
worshipping gods killing people rescuing
people collecting resource destroying
resources and then rewards that these
stars can give you with price
adjustments combat help that give you
buffs that can help you build new
buildings which give you other benefits
they'll loan you equipment they'll give
you equipment they'll you know we'll
send henchmen to help you and and then
punishments the same way they can do all
they can do all the negative they can
raise their prices it can embargo items
to you they can debuff you they can send
out hostile drones to get you all kinds
of crazy stuff but this is a list would
just keep growing and growing and
growing but they all all of these have
to come off the macro bars which are net
effect of the three of the three um
passion ballers all right so let's talk
about a dramatic event so we want in
this world my god I'm speaking very
generally about stories so far and this
conversation will stay pretty particular
and general about story you know the
goal obviously we're not this is not the
level of a Last of Us story here I'm
talking about or a Bioshock story we're
trying to keep it very simple but I want
you to keep in mind that the goal
eventually will be once we have these
systems in place to actually apply real
interesting meaningful story but this
system comes first so let's talk about
an event a very traditional event here
so we know Authority that and we feed
back to the player of that if there's a
to orc stars or disapprove of the player
and any three other stars approve of the
player on their macro bar to a certain
extent a red dragon will appear in the
world and the red dragon is what we call
an unaligned star
he has no village all he cares about is
death and destruction all he cares about
he doesn't care who you do it to he just
wants him dead and so he's got a macro
bar you see he's had all these things he
can do for you all those black lines on
the macro bar and the more terrible
things you do the more ding the more
stuff he gives you he shows up in battle
to help you know you kill or excuse and
he kills some elves and you burn them
down their village and he gives you a
kill base buff and then you do what you
do so many terrible things you start a
dwarfing goblin war through a series of
quests and now he says dude I will
destroy any town you want for me just
give me the word and I'll go kill it and
that has obviously a major effect in the
game it kills a bunch of stars really
changes the battlefield but that's
that's the end game with the dirt with
the red dragon but it's also a silver
dragon if you remember your donors and
dragons the metallic dragons are nice
and the color dragons are bad Lisa its
way Mike and when I remember it so the
silver dragon only wants you to do
constructive things he doesn't care for
who you want you to help he wants you to
build he wants you to craft crops he
wants to do all those nice things but
you want to punch him in the face
sometimes he's so nice but there is a
zero-sum game and obviously he's got he
can give you a whole bunch of stuff but
there's a zero-sum game between the red
dragon and the silver dragon
so as you're making one of them happy
you're going to piss the other one off
and if you get a dragon if you get one
dragon really happy at you will guess
what the other dragons me super unhappy
with you and I need to tell you what
happens after that
so there's this complex web of sort of
alliances allegiances
different few no even then villages
aren't holistic and and and and and you
know they have their people have
different feelings within villages and
you're going to have to either when you
go into the game and play them off each
other you're going to have to decide
make some decisions I'm going to be mr.
orc this time I'm going to totally hook
up with the orc village but it to me
it's you're not going to get a bunch of
things and other goes we're going to
play them all off against each other or
you're going to keep both dragons sort
of you know in the middle but you're not
going to go too far with either one of
them or you wanted rec with them at all
these are all be choices in the game and
then you throw in more factions
here's the dwarves here's the goblins
all with their stars all with all with
their drones and and they all play into
the other systems they all speak
everything every new thing you add can
speak to all the other things that exist
now let's talk about an event another
really original event from the north
comes hordes of white zombies now that
has a net effect of adding a passion to
almost everybody in the world which is
holy [ __ ] I'm scared of the white
zombies and that's going to so no matter
how they feel about each other and that
was you know if you look at Game of
Thrones you know the the Nights Watch
went around to all the kings and all the
can they said hey help us a little with
some beads and only one of them showed
up you know but they all cared about
them various various degrees so you're
going to have different passions but
maybe there's me a dwarven necromancer
who's like well this is awesome I love
the fact that these guys showed up
because I'm a necromancer and so these
major events can change the the ground
underneath you they won't change the
existing passions but maybe they can add
new passions and give you a different
way to influence people because new
things have happened in the world
alright so as I said before I hinted
that before none of this is like
earth-shattering from a oh my god that
that's an amazing narrative but it's
about the opportunities and it's about
opportunities to make this replayable
narrative so we we had to build a system
first and this one this is building the
system independent of a game it applies
to this could apply to a first person
game as comply to a fantasy game this
comply to an RTS system really can apply
to pretty much any game
but I gave you serve an example of RPG
but you're building a web of nearly
infinite relate
ship states and these states these
changes in these states were where
you'll fire off our TM professionally
crafted well written well acted
narrative and dialogue but they will be
they won't spawn off trigger points in
the world they'll spawn off a confluence
of all these things interacting with
each other so you know here's a bunch of
character saying I've been saying a
bunch of things that will be you know
obviously it's all placeholder dialogue
though but they are saying except for
oMG that will be in the game they are
set you know they're these are spawning
off of what you do and and as their you
influence your passions they will react
to you let's go for a detailed example
of sort of a story that can form around
this there's you there's a dwarf named
Betty and an elf named Veronica
they are both have each of them have a
passion and please like this mace like
not all women are looking only to get
married and it's not like I'm not making
a statement about sexual interactions
heroes it's just a Betty and Veronica
example pretend they're dudes and say
they're both looking for marriage and
with you so that's her passion now you
start interacting with them you start
doing things to impress and make for and
build a relationship Veronica so she
says I would really like you to meet my
parents you have to that's a quest you
have to go to this quest fight a bunch
of monsters deal with a bunch of crap
craft some flowers you know craft a bag
of donuts or whatever and bring it to
her parents the quest one boom you that
make some her passion for you grow and
her macro bar starts to move and she's
like oh thank you for meeting my parents
here's a template plus ten sword and III
eel sword um then you uh you craft Betty
a house and she likes that a lot she
gives you she gives you a buff that
gives you plus ten approval to all your
actions ended in her town in the out of
town so every time you get a every time
you do something for somebody else
they're gonna
hence the effect of that because Betty's
say nice things about you and will
support our content she'll be walking
around town saying how awesome you are
singing your praises and you'll see
people react to that and we'll reinforce
that with the game system now if you
step back and look at Betty and Veronica
well they're not just two different
women they're marrying them will yield
very different effects really Betty's
about crafting Betty's about Betty's
about building Betty that he's about
crops
Betty's about sort of earthy things and
Veronica's more royalty and she can give
you like lots of nice weapons and
treasures and castles and things like
that and you look at them like okay well
you know where's my strategy here as a
gamer how do I want to approach
situations just like any character
decision you make in a game but you're
going to decide you can't marry them
both so you're going to have to decide
and in this case let's say you choose
Veronica and you decide you want the
combat benefits so you really start
pushing on her you build her an
enchanted garden and that's like that
moves her macro bar up to the point
where she unlocks the wedding quest for
you and the wedding quest is craft a
tuxedo build a chapel get the priests
macro bar to a certain place where he's
willing to marry you by doing a bunch of
crap for him in any any of his past it's
not just one quest getting all his
passions to a point where the macro bar
yields he's going to marry you and then
you go on a quest to a dungeon to find
the ring that she wants um I step ahead
for a second now but remember as you're
pleasing Veronica you're pissing off
Betty because she still has hopes for
you but that doesn't mean that you have
to go on one track and commit to it you
can waver you can go back and forth and
you can excite it take your time and
decide but you know that way I can't
have negative impacts because she's what
they're both watching what you do and
they're pulling away for you or pulling
towards you so when you complete the
quest you finally said well I played I
led I let him I let Betty on long enough
I got to finally you know put a ring on
it I'm gonna marry Veronica and you do
that and ding that moves from a crowbar
doh point where she gives you
combat buff a permanent comm above a
thousand gold and a castle and the
castle gives you all these other
benefits for yourself but Betty Betty is
unhappy with you so she removes the buff
from you that enhanced you no say you're
crafting abilities before and when when
she hears the marriage and really sinks
in and you haven't done any you remember
you could still make her happy somewhat
by doing other things on her passion
line but say you don't do that she
really goes negative on you she says
well you can't craft crops in the dwarf
village anymore and that's a real
problem for you because you really
wanted that but you made a choice you
made a choice in like in a big boy you
got to live with that choice big boy or
girl you remember that choice but here's
a twist we will write different
characters for these people we would
give them their own hopes and dreams
their feelings you know you know there
are different characters we've written
lots of different characters their
showdown and Elizabeth and and Andrew
Ryan they all have different characters
that are basically independent of any
game systems and people like them or
hate them or like spending time or don't
spend time with them well independent of
how you feel about them systemically
you're going to feel about them
hopefully if we do our job right as
people so you may marry Veronica you may
like Betty a lot more and you're going
to have to live with that because you're
gonna have to spend a lot of time you
know she'll go on quest with you and
things like that and spend time with you
and interact with you you're going to
have to think about that the player is
going to be sort of making choices
between what he wants sort of you know
what character he likes or character
likes to spend time with and what he
needs to grow in this game fortunately
unlike life you can replay it and marry
the other one next time so with good
writing
hopefully players should be able to make
you tap the balance physical gain versus
these emotional fulfillment decisions
and with all these systems your ability
to play one off the other the ability to
you know kind of keep people happy but
where these can people kind of be those
who are really happy but by betraying
friends they've had moving their macro
bars down there will be false friends
leading people on betrayals and
reconciliations you know you could if
you do your job right end up simulating
something along
lines of this or any other any other
sort of narrative experience where you
have lots of people who are plotting
against each other and playing one off
each other you could make you can make I
think you could with within grasps start
to try to simulate something like that
but driven not by your TV set driven by
you some of hidden passions hidden
passion so characters that let's just
say for argument's sake have three
passion it's the beginning but maybe
they also hidden passions which are not
revealed at first these are a resource
knowing about people's hidden passions
means you can impact upon them in
different ways you don't know about the
passion you can't impact upon the
passion and it's a resource that other
characters can give you about themselves
depending on their macro bar or you they
can give you they can give you gossip
about characters they know so let's say
you've been friend you've been friends
with Romeo if you really grown his macro
bar and one of the one of the thresholds
is hey I know about this cool quest why
don't you come on it with me and we'll
share the riches so you go on the quest
with Romeo and he like tells you about
himself about his hopes and his dreams
and how he really strangely hates
dwarves in a creepy way and he tells you
he writes poetry and read through some
of his poems you're maybe getting to
know him and you're about to go in the
dungeon and you go down the dungeon and
you sort of help him on the quest
complete the quest that moves him a
crowbar to another stage thing and he
says I'm going to reveal to you one of
my secret passions I'm in love with
Julie at the orc and so now you know a
new passion about Romeo because you
spend time with him you've interact with
him and you've given him what he wanted
on his bars and he now you got to make a
decision because you know now that he's
going to like it when you when you beat
up on orcs because he's in love with
Julie at the orc so you have to make
some decisions do I continue this
friendship with Romeo do i or did I
abandon the orcs like what do I do here
and so you can see it's a new passion
here so the orc reinforcements come in
in this in this dungeon and boo
one of them's Juliet so now you have to
make a decision about what you're going
to do obviously he's not going to kill
her what you do but then your eyes say
you're on the same quest with a
different character he doesn't care it's
just me let's go kill all those
[ __ ]
okay so replayability and that's central
to this games we made generally have had
two add-ons I'm very fond of them but
they're add-ons or not add-ins you add
it to the end of the experience game
flick Civilization XCOM add in to the
situation allow you allow you to start
the game over and play a very different
feeling version of the game so obviously
the player will have each playthrough
they can choose different stars to
befriend different different people to
take onboard different people to turn
against and that's player driven they
can support the same characters but to
different extents then let's talk about
the passion pool okay so let's say Frank
the orc actually has ten we right
produce record casks 10 different whole
passion sets for him but in each game we
only reel through only get three we
choose at random three of them so like
we all have different stages in our life
where we care about different things
you're encountering Frank at a different
stage of his life he's still the same
guy still the same character but at one
point of his life he cares about hating
the elves who temple the old gods and he
wants to woo Barbara but then he's
married he still hates the elves and but
he says marriage is not going the way he
thought so maybe he secretly loves Roma
the elf and you know he's you want
something different his life now and he
also is you know he look into his
retirement he really wants a pieces of a
cat's eye medallion and so he's a
different goddess time and he maybe have
other secret passions so that's you know
when you come into the game you'll still
see the same people but though they may
have different goals and of course we
can make overtime new passions new
characters new quests new factions all
those things available as time goes on
so for instance you add a new faction
the werewolves the orc does not like
werewolves but one of the elves has a
thing for one of the werewolves so these
are new passions you can play off and
the werewolves have their own passions
of course okay and this is not a promise
of any
we have no idea whether we're doing
anything like this but let's talk about
co-op multiplayer say my brother and I
are playing the game together and we
have in real life we have a great
relationship but we come across some
elves he's done a lot of work friending
the elves he spent a lot of resources
befriending the elves the elves hate me
hate my guts and they see me and they
restart I get ambushed by the Elsa's I
pissed off somebody's macro bar to a
certain point they send an ambush at me
and among you know I'm on you know the
headset with my brother he's in New
Jersey I'm in Boston and I'm like stoop
come on the officer attacking me help me
out he's like well I don't know I really
those elves are been pretty good to me
so sorry Ken and you know I'm dead and
he's like hangs LDLs and you know we may
we if you're a play diplomacy which one
my favorite games of all time you know
the effects of some of these betrayals
that can happen in games one of my
dearest friends in the world I still
kind of hate because of a game of
diplomacy because it's the game
relationship versus your personal
relationship so all these relationships
if you bring real people into it I think
can really expand to a whole new level
that's it
questions
start there in a lot of what you said
the NPCs were aware of all actions that
were taken by the player how things like
lying and taking actions in secret be
managed in this kind of system
I haven't I'd hits a really good
question I think that's beyond the scope
of what I thought about yet I think it's
something you could it could complicate
things it could also be a really cool
thing but I think that how information
gets propagated maybe we need some kind
of feedback about information
propagating throughout the world maybe
of some ways to keep information from
propagating maybe there's tools you can
have for that I think it's a really
interesting space I just haven't thought
it through yet but it's a good question
we'll go step two there's so one
potential issue I can see with this is
that a lot of times and you know stories
and TV shows and most interesting things
are when a character feels very
conflicted about another character like
for example when Deborah finds out that
Dexter is a serial killer I'm sorry
spoilers she's conflicted with her
police values but also with their family
values and it seems like with your
system you would still have a sort of
common tutorial explosion of sort of art
and voice acting and writing because you
need to sort us consider all these
possibilities every passion that each
character might be in not just the macro
passion but also the specific states of
the non-natural - yeah I think there's a
I'm not in any way pertained there's a
there's a trivial amount of writing work
to be done here I think there's a
substantial amount of writing work the
difference is because they bounce off
each other and they can they play off
each other they're reusable and they can
they can appear in different games they
can appear in different contexts but
there's still a full plenty big writing
job to be done here I'm not trying to
write less I'm trying to write stuff
that can be reused and replayed in
different contexts but you're completely
right and starting to track that
combinatorial explosion is going to be I
think one of the first steps when you
start doing the math to see how much of
you can really support but writing is
relatively cheap it's what I what
excites me about this is the fact that
it's different
and it's driven by the player so you
know you can you have to scale that to
taste and what you can afford
Thanks thank you hi system sounds very
interesting the likeability of a star
towards a player made me think a bit of
Dragon Age Origins and something that
was kind of a letdown in that system was
that I was never motivated for a
character to dislike me other than you
know player impose narrative yes my
guy's a paladin type character I'm not
going to like the witch yeah but in the
end I needed everyone to like me so I
can get the benefits from them liking me
so on so forth so I have to do actions
that kind of went against my character
to fulfill the game needs how do you
plan on balancing that or giving
positive rewards for some players
dislike well I don't get I don't think
positive rewards for making people hate
you is where I thing i think the
zero-sum game is where that comes in
because like i was talking to a friend
of mine about he worked on a game
created a game called dogs he's right
there and you know the dog would like
you or not like you depending on
different things but because the dog was
only actor in the world you had that
challenge exactly what you're talking
about is like what's the you're not
going to kick the dog in the face you
know so like how do you how do you deal
with that and that's why the zero-sum
games are so important just like real
life you can be nice to somebody all day
long and just so being nice to that
person and ignoring the other person hey
you're doing a development your wife's
at home waiting for you a zero-sum game
and that's the problem that I think we
want to highlight because I don't think
the choice of good and evil to me is
always that challenging thing is like
well I don't want to be a jerk but just
by what you don't do or what you do for
others makes you a jerk to some people
because they don't like it hey you went
to dinner with that guy
[ __ ] you and I think that's the heart of
how you deal with that problem thank you
it sounded like um sorta talk about all
the cursing by the way the foul it
sounded like you're sort of stars were
fixed characters even though they were
going to have like differ
passions every time you restarted the
game sounded like Frank the orc was
always going to be the blacksmith in the
shop maybe I didn't get that but um so I
was wondering what are your thoughts on
sort of having Stars emerge based on who
the player wants to interact with so I
think that I mean one thing I like about
these sorry playable games is they let
you set all the sliders and all the
variables so you know I don't think I'm
cool and a lot of these get trickier
once you have things like leaderboards
and achievements and some like that but
you can invalidate you know those things
for the purpose of the game but I'm
really a fan of saying I want to play a
game where Frank has these passions and
this guy has these passions if you want
that because it's your game and the
system I'm like where you can't wait do
that again like infinite right this game
I think would allow for that so I I
support it in concept absolutely because
I that's the kind of games I love I like
setting every little checkbox myself
makes my it makes it the game mine so it
seemed like there is a might be a bit of
a disconnect between the interesting
dynamics of each quest and the somewhat
selfish rewards you get for it possibly
a boost for a main quest how do you
think this game would work if you
eliminate these reward boosts or even
eliminate a main quest news and these
side quests were the entire game so I
don't actually like so main quest is a
really interesting question
I don't do you need a main quest I don't
actually know we've been talking about
that like because a main quest implies a
macro narrative that moves on and macro
narrative fights against this sort of
experimental game like you know again
going back to civilization there's a
macro narrative in the sense that you
have five six different and actually had
a bunch of slides about this but I
thought it was beyond the scope of the
talk like wind conditions and things
like that potential wind conditions I
thought that was game design not a
system design so you could like say I
can win the world by destroying one of
the villages I can win the game by
showing the vote I can win it by making
them all like me a certain amount no by
whatever you know you can set different
wing conditions or you can sort of set a
macro story but I much rather have these
events that happen that change at a time
it's like the white Walker example I
gave
then enforcing a story again I don't
know if that's going to work like you
know and I'm knowing myself you know you
can oat you always get drawn into what
you know and what you do so what we're
that's why we're sort of really trying
to you know reset here because we've
done the same thing for so long so I
think there's my discipline is to always
try to start with what do we need to
make this a great game and right now I
don't know if that's a macro story the
stories may all come out of these
entirely player driven experiences so
how are you modeling the passions there
is a talk from the AI summit two years
ago by Stefan viewer from story bricks
yep that I've talked to Stefan yeah
presented kind of a great way of
modeling passions I was wondering how
close it is to what he was talking about
so why does one of those people is out
there that is thinking about these
things and we've had a bunch of
conversations and I think that you know
what I like about this is that there are
people and you know some other friends
of mine the industry are talking about
this what I the sort of the place where
I've been thinking we're actually going
to get together later that I've been
thinking since I last talked to him I
sort of really focused on my focus has
been on making rather making characters
at the range of emotions making a
character the very few passions these
three passions and all these zero-sum
game situations because I'm probably
less ambitious than he is to some degree
and really and as a writer I'm like how
do i how do I make characters come out
rather than people come out so I think
that's really where the direction I've
been going in that could look that could
all change he may we may sit down I'm a
lunch lady movie like you're a [ __ ]
idiot let me tell you why and this whole
talk is a waste of everybody's time
but that's where since our last
conversation a couple of months ago
that's where I've really been going with
this and you know we sort of he and I
have both been tuned I found he called
me after was like oh I talked to I
announced his talk he's like I've been
working on something very similar so I
think this is one of reason you want
transparency here you want openness is
you want to be able to talk the reason
I'm doing this talk is you want to
engage everybody's brain because I think
it's an important problem I think it's
hard to say hard to deny it's an
important
and the more of us who are thinking
about it and that's why I wanted this
you know out there and it's pretty early
is so we can have lots of smart people
like Stefan and talking about this
Thanks hi hi
what about modifying passions what if
you could do something to convince Frank
that elves aren't actually so bad it
could still be zero zone because now the
other works really hate both Frank and
you yes so I think that's a possibility
like my sense is that it I'm not ready
to play the drum fills yet you know I'm
sort of getting the rhythm down and so I
think that's you can there's lots of
ways to play on the system and to
interact with the system my first step
our team we're talking to our Garland's
our lead technology guy about this a lot
it's like I think the first step to
modeling this is you design a paper and
pen adventure you use doesn't d20 system
right you set up a bunch of quest you
said over bunch of characters passions
and the only thing you use a computer
for and the first test is to track the
passions and the macro passions and the
end the interactions of those because
that's a lot of data but you could just
with pen and paper start to play out
this system and see how possible it is
and see how it works and that's probably
our first step before we even really
touch a computer you need to probably do
this in a database application and then
we will we'll build from there but you
know the options to expand upon it and
play with it are infinite presuming that
you you know don't overflow what I call
player RAM like how much how much stuff
can they keep in their head at once and
it may be a great idea and I'm you may
play with it well just like all these
ideas may be a great idea you may play
with it it may be a terrible idea it's
hard to say until you try it but that's
one of the goals is it's a starting
point all right yes so I'm a designer on
the civilization franchise and I wanted
to say how I feel yet designer on the
civilization free office I'm a fanboy
yeah I'm happy to hear that yeah we're
big fans of your work as well and it's
exciting to see your approach one of the
things the macro sort of moved modifier
reminds me of especially is the sort of
opinion system that we use in Civ and I
think the examples that you've used are
definitely the more most colorful and
interesting and kind of prone
narrative flavor when you know you have
the one work feeling this way in the
other work feeling this way and kind of
like aligning the passions in such a way
that the player works towards you know
they're really liking you were really
disliking you and I was wondering if
you've thought about or if you have any
ideas about how to kind of avoid a lot
of the NPC's ending up in that kind of
like middle gray space because like you
there are ways to solve it with like the
combinatorial writing explosion of like
yeah maybe you built the temple for the
old gods but you did Elfquest so like
you're in this mutual state or this NPC
but it's kind of hard to reflect I mean
to me that's a balance problem because
what you the rewards in the middle space
are going to be pretty marginal right
versus the big rewards you're going to
have to really take some big swings with
people so you want gameplay to kind of
drive players towards yeah edges okay so
you can keep you know getting ten five
percent price reductions at the store
from everybody that's not really going
to move the needle to really accomplish
those larger quest sorry to really
accomplish this large request you're
going to have to get people really
Cashen about you one way or the other
and as I said the zero-sum games is
gonna lead to you make some real friends
you can make some real enemies yeah and
the transparency will help players get
there exactly cool thank you thank you
well thank you for the talk you talk a
lot about how it's very player focused
all the actions from the player those
decisions but you also mention these
hidden systems that you under drummer by
having these relationships and I'm
curious in minimal interaction what
happens when you see a confrontation and
you step back do the AI find out hidden
passions of each other on their own what
happens if you hide in the bushes during
the events that are occurring so a
passion remember is on as far as I think
about it at this early stage is only
what a character feels about a situation
relationship to you and that you can
impact upon so I mean the notion of a
player knowing about another player a
character knowing about another
character's passion is relevant and how
they talk about them you know we can cut
make colorful stuff yeah I heard on
Romeo
is that weird taste you know or as I
said he can reveal potentially if you
one of the people's macro bars could be
revealing passion a secret passion about
somebody else and that just basically is
another meter you can push on for them
so I don't know if it's meaning if
there's like game too but there's you
know systemic meaning and what you're
talking about
I'm not saying there couldn't be but as
I'm thinking about it right now I don't
think it's I like we when we did this
thing and a bunch of us worked on it
what we kept coming back to was it's
very easy to step out of the system and
start coming up with five yeah just come
up with narrative things that could
happen but we kept saying no no it has
to come out of it has to spawn out of
this system and so you don't want to
just service saying oh these guys start
feeling this way about you but
independent of the passion system
because then you're just you know
throwing here to serve throwing
artificial things into the mix you're
throwing in hacks basically and we want
the system to work at a core basis not
saying we can't expand the system but we
want everything to be driven from the
core system thank you thank you my
question is about clear choices and like
I was wondering like there are four
every simulation ax store
narrative-driven player who's all about
like portraying the character in an RPG
there's quite a few more who are playing
the game mostly because they can maybe
like the choice system and they like how
the system enables them to basically
kill everyone and they care not for who
the for whom the blood flows but I was
wondering um how would you handle
certain questions yeah how would you
handle incasa's inconsistent player
choices in delivering in delivering a
coherent narrative experience through a
system without necessarily using a
zero-sum game so I think the biggest
problems going to come out with Thresh
holding back and forth between like if
you're constantly moving somebody back
and forth towards a feeling towards you
you I think that you you may find your
you know I'm talking about like well I
did the saying he loves me now he closes
the store now he opens a certain eye
closes the store well you could reflect
that certainly in dialogue like dude
you're driving me crazy but you could
also potentially start putting in
modifiers like once you get past a
certain threshold you know on a positive
it's harder to make them dislike you you
built up credibility and trust with them
but that would have to be transparent
and systemic and I think you may want to
do that to avoid situations like that
and once somebody hates you you really
got to work you can get them back but
you really really got to work we had a
notion walking at the end that you
couldn't come back from it and I think
in my experience you know that's
probably less interesting that if
there's a way to come back to what's
super hard
that would be kind of cool that person
probably always carry you know that
negative mathematical twist we put on it
will come across the narrative like yeah
you know okay but I still don't trust
you you know where if they got into the
same point without going so negative
they wouldn't have that I said I don't
trust you line they would just like okay
well okay I'll do this thing thank you
thank you I I was wondering when do you
think to input an endgame of the system
like and what would you do for the
player at the end would it be a fall out
style like recapping of all the
relationships you've built or I think
that's probably beyond the scope like of
what I'm talking about because I think
that's a game that's a game design
decision like a particular game where
this is a system like you know how do
you want to end it there's a million
ways you can end it I don't actually
think this dictates any of those things
you could you could have a bunch of
narrative events you could have when
certain thresholds are met like I said
you could have when certain towns or to
try there's a million end games you
could do I think that's not what my
first priority so all I can do is beg
ignorance on this one and say that's
something for the down the road yeah so
a lot about similar system is quite a
bit and I find it very interesting but
one of the conflicts I always find with
it is that it seems very hard to design
a sort of deeply thematic narrative that
deals with these types of open-ended
systems given that you dealt a lot with
deeply thematic narratives do you see a
solution to that or do you see these as
sort of mutually exclusive types of
narratives um I think it's a really good
question and the honest thanks the
honest answer is it's it's hard to say
and that's part of the experiment like I
I want to get up here and say like we
could definitely have the best of both
worlds
I don't know if I can say that yet
because in the same way like
civilization has a narrative right it's
as meta-narrative sports have a
narrative like when you play a football
game there's a bunch of rules but it not
only has a narrative it has a
meta-narrative like whoa that guy just
left the Giants and now he's on the
Chargers out of team yeah all right
and but and so he's got this rivalry
going so this is meta-narrative and he's
he he just [ __ ] that guy's wife and
like oh my god what's going to happen on
the field so there's a meta-narrative
around those things and I think there
will be a narrative that forms in this
much more supportive than civilization
are closed because of all these
characters in the dialogue and the
ability to have you know a multi multi
track feeling of characters very
multitrack feelings about you I think
that's going to be a very interesting
question that's going to be the goal and
we're just going to have to see how that
plays out but it's a really good
question but yes it will buy it yeah so
the world that you describe it would
only change if the player decides to do
something to change it but like
something out for instance stalker in my
opinion did really well or in a really
interesting way is that things happen
even without you doing anything about it
and the world itself is alive and
changing even when you're not there yeah
how would that I like how would you
implement that like this so the white
walkers example I gave is interesting
one of it that could be something that's
spawned off of a bunch of things you do
or we could just you know sometime roll
the die or plan or authorial II plan on
it to happen and you see a lot of there
are a lot of board games actually where
events happen like ex-cons a great
example where they sort of put a new
template of event that comes in that
changes how you have to play so I don't
know yet I think it will allow for
either one I want to make sure the
player feels that they're dry that they
are at the helm of the other hand you
know like you know starting took my
friend drew yes or at Ned Stark you know
and how Ned thinks he can play everybody
off one another and everybody can keep
everybody happy he finds out what
happened he tries to keep everybody
happy and then you have but then you
have situations that happen outs
out of your control and I think that
that is something interesting ability
Game of Thrones had always happening
people think they have things in charge
and then Tyrion comes in and shoots you
in the gut with a crossbow and so I
think you have to balance that to make
sure the players feel feels that they
are the driving force in the world but
maybe you do want the White Walkers to
appear by the by you know Fiat Thanks
all right I think that's all we can do
right now thanks guys